Democrats plan five different responses
to the president's address why stop at
five sounds like a really unified party
to me they couldn't pick just one they
got to go to five people that's very
diverse well that includes a speech by
Bernie Sanders tonight that's the one
I'm looking for were doing Maxine Waters
tomorrow we thought that was tonight so
if you have that many messages do you
really have a message at all let's go
back to our panel Philippe does this
party have a unified response to Donald
Trump
obviously he's unified the Republican
Party it's interesting to look back a
year ago year and a half ago during the
campaign he's the most divisive
Republican he's ripping the party to
shreds I love looking back on those
sound bites from some of our friends on
the other cable channels he's unified
the party unlike anyone I've seen since
maybe right after 2001 or maybe Reagan
tax cuts he'll do that I do want to take
issue though with your numbers she said
there were five Democrats I think
therefore I'm not going to count Bernie
as Oh an actual Democrat fair point I
have to say that a litigant hits both
sides I'll give you that okay you know
people have different messages but you
know what ten people can talk and no
one's going to get the attention the
person it does on the night of the stage
yeah well but it's a bit unless you need
some more water and lean over like some
people are gonna be talking more about
why was there car with hood opa hind his
sweating a lot the sweat is heart
members it's a nod because it wasn't it
was Nixon Kennedy and Nixon was sweating
in this in case it was the Kennedys it
was interested in Republicans you're
saying it not me but it's strange I mean
you know for the Democrats to trot out a
young new fresh face but but his name is
Joe Kennedy that's their fresh face the
dynasties aren't a good thing they want
to get where their tariffs catch the
Clintons get past the bush Kamala Harris
summon someone I would have put her out
there she's interesting she's an
interesting person but I don't Joe
Kennedy it's he looked like he went to
too many Tony Robbins seminar a lot of
stresses on the wrong words and the and
it's hard because they follow Trump I'm
it's really hard and I didn't I never
did I've said what was the broken-down
car in the background for
clear because Fall River is known for
its broken down old mills angles and a
Bengal sing in the back maybe should
have had a patriot sign back down maybe
we're playing the Superbowl
Byron it's not fair though because we've
talked about I know you and I've talked
about poor old Rubio or Bobby Jindal no
it's Filipe said the water or the sang
out to an empty room it just it never
works so I think we should just dispense
with them all together just happen to
have some other type of event well you
can't win and the Democrats couldn't win
but but tonight but what they did do
does tell us something about them and us
and about them and they are really
deeply divided it appears to be and in
kind of in interest groups the the fact
that they would have all of these
different responses basically ranging
from the center left to the far left and
the that that was all throughout the the
Democratic presence I saw a tweet
tonight about representative Gutierrez
the the Democratic congressman who was
wearing three different items of
clothing to indicate he had well he had
times up pen for sexual harassment he
had a butterfly pen for the dreamers and
he was wearing an African cloth to
protest Donald Trump's [ __ ] car I'm
not expected to defend the other type of
we're not a walking billboard at the
cinemas there was a joy read tweet just
for the heck of X it's midnight past
midnight joy read tweet tonight this is
what it is put okay it says church
family police military the national
anthem Trump trying to call on the
tropes of 1950s era nationalism the goal
of this speech appears to force the
normalization of Trump on the terms of
the bygone era his supporters are
nostalgic for Phillippe does that sum up
the party that now we're all upset when
Charles family military and the national
anthem get mentioned well look jokes
aside and back to the point I was making
is that it was a very traditional State
of the Union dress I think
that's a problem because he's not a
traditional president no but here's why
your part here's why the words you use
in the words you don't use Telegraph to
the government to the people what your
priorities are and I think the point of
what he didn't say is important Cory was
mentioning and you were saying that he
really put America first first I think
he put the threats we faced last or not
at all and everyone's gonna jump on me
the minute I say Russia but let's forget
about the memo and all that greg Pompeo
president Trump's CIA director said
Russians are going I would screw with
that sorry Mike Pompeo Mike Pompeo is
gonna screw with us Russians gonna screw
with us in November in 2018 this is
position of the intelligence agencies
why does the president say it's not say
that we will not tolerate that if Iran
we're going to screw around with our
elections it would have been in the
speech if North Korea was going to be in
the speech that's that's a fair point I
think I might have thrown that in there
my question to you is and I don't
remember and I might be wrong did Barack
Obama reference the 50 million personnel
files that China stole from the Office
of Personnel Management
among them mine and many others and
their cyber spying are their stealing of
supercomputing technology they're
stealing of our intellectual property
challenging us at every level Russia's
economy is smaller than the size of
France China has a large and larger
standing army than ours right now for
airplanes five feet I know the fighter
etins us at every turn we go all around
the world all the time why is it either
but you because why should not get it
because you're obsessing on it for a
reason for political expedience my point
because I don't like Russians Mikey they
can squirrely Carla I don't recall your
party being obsessed with the Soviet
Union what it was the Soviet Union they
were this is d'etat central with a
Democrat Party that's all we wanted now
it's Russia Russia Russia that's all you
guys can say because otherwise you have
to talk about why the economy is doing
well why consumer confidence is up why
business investment is up and why this
president is actually instilling an
American exceptionalism that I think had
been beaten down frankly for many many
years why does that preclude protecting
us from exterior
I don't think he is do I not say it I if
he said it you'd be on to the next thing
no I wouldn't actually I don't think I'd
notice every times the Democrats say
Russia
I say China and they never have an
answer because China we can handle we
never did
he never really focused we're talking
about President Trump right here did we
don't but we did mention it across the
board we did we did have eight years of
the Democratic president who got kind of
run over pretty badly by the Democrats
even by the Russians including the reset
effort which failed and including the
fact that that everything that did
happen you know one and all the other
issues and wants to talk we never talked
about uranium one Barack Obama was in
the office America tax cuts jobs
unemployment security for people
infrastructure spending god and your
country look that's what the state union
is about it's about making people proud
to be Americans again I think it's
except it's not easy outing 90% of your
party being happy with it and 40% of the
opposing party not I really don't see
what the rah-rah Zoe but I think it's
always hard to be the party out of power
on the first day of the Union speech
Obama hit it out of the park on his
first I really think he did a great job
in his first speech it's not like as a
Republican I'm gonna like it but it's
not easy and the country's doing really
well
Trump has some problems to deal with and
he's got to deal with them this
investigation is an albatross no doubt
but it's not easy to be the party out of
power we'll see for how long you are out
of power but if you can which I'm not
sure that that performance tonight is
going to help much in November I just
don't well if Democrats don't the
economy is gonna help in November and if
it keeps going the way it's going the
resistance is gonna be a resistance to
progress